good morning Hank it's Tuesday so one
night about 15 years ago I went to a bar
in Chicago and through a mutual friend I
made the acquaintance of a mathematician
named Daniel Biss I was surprised by how
much I enjoyed talking to Daniel that
evening on account of how throughout my
life I had worked pretty hard to avoid
interactions with professional
mathematicians like I chose the college
I attended in part because you didn't
have to take math to graduate also it's
hard to make friends in adulthood and
I've never been good at it but as Daniel
and I played an exceptionally poor game
of pool that night I had the feeling
that I was making a friend and it turns
out I was right Daniel and I have now
been friends from within a third of our
lives he is the smartest person I have
ever known he was 25 when we met and had
already gotten his PhD in math from MIT
and was working as a professor at the
University of Chicago but he has never
treated me as anything other than an
intellectual equal
and we remained close throughout big
changes in our lives I met Sarah and
moved to New York and then eventually
Indianapolis and became a dad Daniel
fell in love with a historian and they
got married and moved to the suburbs of
Chicago and had two beautiful kids
everything was good and normal and then
one day Daniel called me with the worst
idea I had ever heard in my entire life
which was that he wanted to leave his
very good job at the University of
Chicago and run for a seat in the
Illinois State House of Representatives
this seemed like a bad idea to me first
because Daniel is like nerdy in my mind
politicians were slick and wore tailored
suits and damn i don't know that daniel
owned a suit Sara and I were in the
audience for Daniel's campaign
announcement and what may have been his
first-ever campaign speech and while his
eloquence and intelligence were obvious
as I was driving home I couldn't help
but think that Daniel how do i phrased
this gently might eventually find his
way back to abstract mathematics and
indeed while Daniel's 2008 race for
state rep was agonizingly close he lost
but he ran again in 2010 and won and
then in 2012 he became a state senator
and over the last eight years Daniel has
become a brilliant politician and an
extraordinarily effective legislator in
a state where it's famously hard to get
anything done he's built bipartisan
support on everything from improving
retirement benefits to ending
exploitative student loan practices and
now he is running for governor of
Illinois not just running in fact he has
a very good chance of winning the
Democratic primary on
March 20th even though his two opponents
are a billionaire who has spent tens of
millions of dollars on advertising and a
literal Kennedy those are the kinds of
people we tend to think of as likely
politicians heirs to famous families
billionaires who can buy all the TV ads
they want I don't generally think of
politicians as people like in my mind
they're somewhere between super heroes
and super villains larger-than-life
characters with tremendous powers
battling it out while the rest of us get
our houses stomped on by their giant
robot suits but imagining electoral
politics that way can become a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy like the main
reason I didn't think Daniel should run
for office all those years ago was
because he didn't seem to me like the
kind of person who would succeed at it
but if people like Daniel don't run for
office or we don't elect them then we
end up with the comic book version of
electoral politics obviously we don't
need lex luthor running our governments
but i also don't think we need superman
we need capable people who know how to
govern who can build consensus who can
listen well and who can hold competing
ideas in their minds when your friend
runs for governor you realize that
politicians are people even the
billionaires even the Kennedys so the
question becomes not who looks or acts
the part or who has the money or
whatever else the question becomes which
of these people no more or less human
than I do I think would be best at this
job and if I thought of politics that
way I would have understood from the
beginning that Daniel would make a
successful politician and for me that is
real cause for optimism I am so proud of
Daniel and really excited to support him
he and I are gonna do a Facebook live
event this Thursday at 1:00 p.m. Eastern
Time I'll ask him some questions you can
ask some to more info in the doobly-doo
below and if you live in Illinois vote
also if you don't live in Illinois vote
Hank I will see you on Friday